today on the mattwall show the ruling
class got together at the met gala last
night to celebrate their wealth aoc was
on the scene in a tax the rich dress was
it a courageous and rebellious display
by the congresswoman or was it rank
shameless hypocrisy we'll discuss also a
new poll shows that an increasing number
of vaccinated americans are cutting off
ties with unvaccinated friends plus
secretary of state lincoln admits that
many of those siv applicant afghans were
admitting into the country are not
actually siv applicants at all and a
male mma fighter enters the ring with a
female fighter and then proceeds to beat
her into submission this is being
celebrated as a brave and beautiful
moment in sports history but i have a
different take as you might expect all
of that and more today on the matt walsh
show
you know one of my great struggles in
life is that i am extremely forgetful
and this is a problem when traveling as
you know i've talked about traveling the
last couple of weeks i i always forget
at least five important things and um
most recently traveling for the last two
weeks i forgot my relief band and i
paid the consequences because we were
taking a lot of
you know ubers and everything around a
lot of a lot of stop and starts and
going around cities and lots of unpaved
roads in new york city because i guess
they've decided that paving is you know
just not
not not worth the time and uh and i was
feeling pretty motion sick and i wish
that i had had my relief banned because
relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that has
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraine hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as you need and it really does work
i can tell you that myself so ensure
that nausea is never the reason to miss
out on life's important moments right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for matt walsh listeners if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
walsh you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off aoc's abuela as far as we know is
still languishing in her unfurnished
puerto rican shack with water pouring
from the ceiling and collecting in tin
buckets strewn across the floor
infamously the congresswoman would not
allow me to step in and
rescue the poor woman from her dire
situation and i can tell you that i am
still personally haunted by that i i
still wake up at some nights in a cold
sweat shouting abuela i'm sorry i tried
abuela
aoc one can assume has slept like a baby
this entire time on the other hand
now i bring this up again because
i thought about abuela last night
when i saw the picture circulating
online of her negligent granddaughter
cavorting with her fellow rich people at
the met gala in new york
tickets for the opulent event cost
somewhere around thirty thousand dollars
a piece and if you want to buy a table
inside the hall to advertise your brand
something to keep in mind for next year
if you're thinking about this for your
business it'll run you about a quarter
of a million dollars
so it is a garish extravaganza
the ostensible purpose of which is to
raise money for the metropolitan museum
of art but in actuality the point is to
celebrate and revel in the ostentatious
wealth of the hollywood government and
media elites in attendance now it may
seem rather hypocritical for aoc to show
up at this carnival of affluence
but don't worry the expensive designer
dress she donned for the occasion which
appears to have been inspired by a
chick-fil-a takeout bag had the words
tax the rich scrawled across it
those words change everything we're
supposed to believe normally it would be
hypocritical for a woman who constantly
rants about rich people to attend a
lavish ball with rich people
so that she could rub elbows with those
same rich people but in this case we're
told her attendance is a bold and brave
and rebellious statement all because of
those words on her dress here she is
explaining her fashion choice my god tax
the rich what a model aoc what up i
didn't know you model as well
damn when aurora and i were first kind
of partnered
uh we really started having a
conversation about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and we said you know we can't just
play along but we need to break the
fourth wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while the met is known for its
spectacle we should have a conversation
about it
ah
yeah have a conversation now here's a
general rule
anytime somebody justifies a particular
action that they've taken by claiming
that they've done it because they want
to start a conversation it means 100 of
the time
that they're full of that's what it
means case in point later that night on
twitter aoc further defended her
attendance saying quote proud to work
with aurora james as a sustainable
focused uh black woman immigrant
designer who went from starting her
dream at a flea market in brooklyn to
winning the cfda against all odds and
then worked together to kick the doors
open at the met the time is now for
child care health care and climate
action for all tax the rich
quick quick fact check on some of this
aurora james the immigrant woman in
aoc's phrase is from ontario now she may
technically be an immigrant but a
fashion designer moving a few hundred
miles from canada to new york
isn't exactly the picture that aoc wants
us to have in mind when she uses the
phrase black immigrant woman also when
she says kick the doors open at the met
what she means is that she took pictures
on the red carpet and then drank
cocktails with her rich friends
that's kicking the doors open
not exactly jesus overturning the tables
and driving the money changers away with
a whip if she had done that
totally different story
and when she says child care and health
care keep in mind that health care for
children as far as the congresswoman is
concerned can often include crushing
their skulls
and throwing them into a medical waste
dumpster
so other than those minor details i'd
say that her description was pretty
accurate
now with that established
i think there are a few other more
general points to be made here first
the problem let's talk about this tax
the rich slogan for a second
the problem is that the slogan is uh you
know it seems to suggest that the rich
right now are not taxed
that's why you say tax the rich because
according to you they're not
if they were being taxed then the slogan
wouldn't make sense it'd be redundant
but that's not true
the rich pay taxes they pay lots of
taxes
they pay the most taxes
they pay the vast majority of taxes
tax the rich sure i agree of course we
should tax the rich
i don't think there are very many people
saying that we shouldn't tax the rich at
all
so here's the good news we do a lot
that's a fact if you hear that the rich
don't pay taxes and you believe it
that must mean that you first of all
don't read very much
and aren't in the habit of researching
claims made by partisans before deciding
to believe them it also means presumably
that you don't make much money yourself
because if you've ever had the
experience of making a small amount of
money and then managing to climb up the
lateral waves i'm not talking about all
the way up to elon musk level i just
mean you made a little bit of money and
then you had some more success and you
made some more money if you've ever done
that
and achieved greater financial success
relative to where you began
you'll have noticed that as you earn
more money the government takes more
money from you
it's a pretty uh inescapable thing it's
it's pretty obvious
and at a certain point you'll observe
with alarm
they begin to take so much of your
income that you question whether the
client was worth it to begin with that's
the case right now
this may come as a shock to anybody who
previously believed that the government
rewards higher income earners by
politely declining to harvest their
income but that's not the case that's
not even close to the case
as it turns out the government quite
enjoys taking people's money
and the more money you have the more it
will want to stick its greasy hands into
your pockets
and when joe biden is running the
government the hand may even linger
there in your pocket for an
uncomfortable and
unnecessary length of time
so
considering that the rich pay most of
the taxes
vast vast majority of the taxes are paid
by the rich where did this idea come
from that they pay no taxes
well here's a good example of how the
propaganda works this is a cbs news
headline from back in june
it says quote
is it's just a headline it says richest
25 americans have a true tax rate of
almost nothing wow
almost nothing
almost nothing what that doesn't sound
fair
jeff bezos doesn't he pays almost
nothing i mean what is that all about
well let's read on
it says the u.s tax system is designed
to be progressive meaning that the
wealthiest citizens pay a greater share
of their income than the less fortunate
but a new pro-public analysis of tax
data on some of the nation's richest
americans comes to the conclusion that
the richest 25 people in the u.s have a
true tax rate of almost nothing
the pro-publica report focuses on what
it calls the true tax rate which it
defines is how much in taxes were paid
by the wealthiest americans annually
versus the estimated growth in their
wealth during that time for instance
amazon ceo jeff bezos paid 1.4 billion
dollars in personal federal taxes
between 20 2006
and 2018
on 6.5 billion that he reported in
income while his wealth increased by 127
billion during that same period
by pro-publica's calculation that
reflects a true tax rate of 1.1 percent
but some
continuing but some tax experts noted
that the analysis compares what they say
are apples to oranges income versus
wealth the irs collects taxes on earned
income and income received through stock
sales dividends and other income
provided by investments it doesn't levy
taxes on unrealized gains or the paper
value of a person's assets ah okay
there it is
when they say that jeff bezos pays
almost nothing what they mean is that he
paid 1.4 billion dollars
nothing
1.4 billion is almost nothing
they justify this claim through a little
sleight of hand trick where they equip
they equate net worth with income
those two things are not the same and
it's a damn good thing that the federal
government doesn't tax your net worth
like it taxes your income because that
would be a disaster for anyone who has
any kind of net worth at all
can you imagine that if that's what you
were doing at the income tax time
you would assess not only your your
income for the year but your entire net
worth
and pay on that
of course many of the people in the
peanut gallery not to be confused with
the elites like aoc
who shout tax the rich don't have any
net worth have never owned anything and
so these are distinctions and points
that go over their head
now i say all this but it's not because
i care deeply about protecting jeff
bezos from higher tax rates
frankly i don't care if his taxes go up
a little bit it doesn't doesn't bother
me
my main problem with raising taxes on on
anyone is that the government already
rakes in three or four trillion dollars
a year in tax revenue and squanders
almost all of it
you know i think it's like it's it's
three and a half trillion i think
they're up to or maybe more
that they bring in tax revenue every
single year
and yet there are people saying they
need more
to do what with
what problem can the government solve
potentially that they can't already
solve with three trillion dollars
a year
there is no problem that can be solved
by giving even more money to this giant
lumbering corrupt wasteful behemoth
raise his taxes if you want whatever but
just just know that it will solve
nothing and that the policy is being
pushed based on lies and bad faith
arguments and it's being believed by
idiots who don't understand the first
thing about how the economy works and
don't even understand the distinction
between income and net worth
second point
why do you think that the rich love aoc
why do they love the tax the rich slogan
you know showing up to the met gala in
an attacks the rich dress
that's not like if i showed up to a
planned parenthood fundraiser in in a in
a t-shirt that said imprison
abortionists
which actually sounds like a great thing
to do maybe i'll do that
but aoc you know she was embraced and
applauded
if i did that i'd be assaulted by
security and thrown out into the street
the rich are fine with the tax the rich
stuff because many of them really don't
mind paying a bit more in taxes that's
not because they're generous i mean if
they were generous they'd be foregoing
they'd forego the 200 000 designer
outfit and the expensive costume ball
and donate that extra wealth to the poor
if you wondered that i mean all these
rich people say oh yeah tax us we should
be paying more
they say while wearing an outfit that
costs more than your house
they could just give up one outfit in
their wardrobe and they could put you
know a family of five in a home and they
choose not to do that
no they they go along with the tax the
rich stuff and they call for higher
taxes themselves because for one thing
it's an easy and relatively cheap way to
virtue signal
and more importantly it gets them closer
to the levers of power
so what do what do all of the people at
the met gala have in common they're all
in the ruling class
aoc the other politicians in attendance
the hollywood degenerates who are there
all of them are in the ruling class
together they have a shared interest
they have shared goals
and that is mainly to maintain and
extend their own influence
sure they'll pay a little more in taxes
what do they care
they know those taxes are being spent by
their comrades to advance their own
ideological interests anyway
and their own financial interests
so for them
for the people at the met gala or the
people who were at the vmas the night
before
big big week for for hollywood
degenerates by the way they could bring
it break out all their
ugly costumes
but for those people
paying taxes that's an investment for
them
they get something in return for it
i mean they get an entire system an
entire political system that works at
their best that's what they get in
return
that's why our objective shouldn't be
simply to tax the rich but rather to
dethrone the ruling class
you'll notice aoc she didn't put that on
her dress
because that's the last thing she wants
to do
third point finally
the rich also aren't too worried about
aoc's tax the rich sloganeering because
they know it isn't serious
anyway she wasn't the only one who
showed up last night with bumper sticker
jargon emblazoned on her outfit there
were plenty of you know celebrities
wearing gaudy but basically
non-political outfits like nas little
little nas x was there
he could be seen here dressed like a
c-3po's gay cousin
but there was also cara de la vigne
whoever that is wearing what looks to be
a fake bulletproof vest with um peg the
patriarchy written on it
and then carolyn b maloney whoever that
is with equal rights for women printed
on a robe that looks like something that
a lesbian episcopal bishop might wear
and then megan rapino with a handbag
featuring the words in gay we trust
you know the other thing you see in all
these pictures
are the wide-eyed star struck reporters
in the background wearing face masks
and hungrily snapping pictures
now the celebrities they're not wearing
face masks
that's actually the greatest hypocrisy
on display in this entire thing
none of them are wearing face masks why
aren't they wearing face masks because
that would ruin their outfits
because it wouldn't look as nice
and it's true that you look ridiculous
in a face mask everybody does
so it's one of the many reasons why i
don't wear them
uh but all the reporters so so the uh
the you know the the servants
are all wearing masks
and the reporters who are also servants
for the for the for the ruling class
they're all in masks
aoc not wearing a mask
none of the rest of them are wearing
masks
this is really the whole thing in a
nutshell isn't it
because truly
nothing says modern leftism like a
gaggle of rich elitists at a 30 000 per
ticket gala walking around in hideous
designer dresses with shallow political
slogans emblazoned across them while an
adoring press looks on drooling into
their muzzles
it's all empty
they're all just cosplaying as political
revolutionaries none of them care about
any of these issues
none of them believe in anything
but their own power and their own
influence
and last night was the perfect
illustration
of that fact
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from our friends over
at mac weldon you know i've become
something of a fashion designer myself
recently with these sweet uh sweet baby
gang t-shirts and i um
i take inspiration from mack weldon in
my new role as a fashion designer not to
blame them for the sweet baby gang
teachers i would never do that
uh but listen the mack weld at mac
weldon they've got something called the
daily wear system the daily wear system
is a selection of clothes rooted in
smart design made with performance
fabrics and built to work together from
breathable t-shirts and polos to stylish
button-ups and shorts underwear and
beyond macweldon makes it easy for you
to dress for work leisure or play for
the ultimate lazy sunday their ace
sweatshorts have modern tailoring and
pair perfectly with their ultra soft
ultra upgraded pima tees uh for for
weekend travels both near and far
they'll their silver knit polo and
radius shorts are the perfect high-tech
highly packable combo they've got it all
at mack weldon so you can buy some time
this fall with the mac weldon daily wear
system for 20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com walsh and enter promo code
walsh that's macweldon.com walls promo
codes for 20 off mac weldon radically
efficient wardrobing all right
poor abuela poor poor abuela
i really do i'm not even
joking i actually do i i think about
abuela
regularly and i wonder how she's doing
however she's doing she's not doing
doing nearly as well as her as her
granddaughter i think that could be
said for sure
let's start with this secretary of state
blinken testified before congress um
about the efforts to
you know get americans out of
afghanistan and to bring afghans into
this country
because right now everything is kind of
uh on its head right we've got americans
in afghanistan we're bringing
afghans we're bringing afghans to
america while leaving americans there
uh everything is is upside down and
backwards and topsy-turvy
but here is we'll start with a couple
clips here this is secretary of state
blanken
during his testimony
um
when he was asked how many of the
afghans that we brought here do not meet
the requirements for special immigrant
visas because we've been told
that these are all siv
applicants special immigrant visas
and uh and many of them are translators
we apparently had a lot of translators
in uh in afghanistan who who knew
you know there's only one there's we had
2 500 troops there
and apparently like a hundred thousand
translators
every every uh american service member
in afghanistan had a whole team of
translators just surrounding him
everywhere he went it would seem
and blanket was asked about this and
here's what he said they were there to
help america how many afghans not
meeting the qualifications of siv have
been brought to the united states
prior to
i i want to know how many afghan
citizens came the united states that had
not met the qualifications for special
immigrant visa
were in the process i don't know
how many did you bring you were just at
dulles how many did you bring
we have we will have by the end of the
month we will have brought a total of
approximately sixty thousand that have
not met the sib process
some of those will be some of those will
have been through the sib process all of
them regardless of siv status will have
gone through rigorous security checks
first at the transition it would be nice
it'd be nice if that was done before we
brought these people to the united
states of america
so he said he won't answer the question
he said 60 000 total and he's not going
to say how many of them
actually meet the requirements versus
how many don't but and the actual answer
that he won't give is well we don't care
what do we care about that that that's
not our concern
you know if we make them citizens well
they vote democrat that's that's one
requirement
we're worried about that but
other than that who cares
uh here's something that he does care
about that is the lgbt community in
afghanistan he says he's very focused
on the the fate of the lgbt community
let's watch
as you know mr secretary the lgbtqia
community in afghanistan is extremely
vulnerable to punitive actions from the
taliban it's important in my view that
we take steps to ensure that those who
would be subjected to violence or worse
because of their sexual orientation or
gender identity are safe
the council of global equality the human
rights campaign and lgbtqia plus refugee
support groups released a 10-point plan
to protect afghan lgbt refugees my
question is have you seen this plan and
if so is the administration prepared to
implement it and is it consistent with
the presidential memorandum of early
2021 uh that speaks of the
responsibility to help afghan refugees
that make it to neighboring states as
outlined in that memorandum
well thank you for very rightly putting
the spotlight on concerns about the
lgbtqi plus community uh in afghanistan
and the particular threat that they uh
they find themselves under uh this is
something that we are focused on i have
not personally seen the report that you
referred to i'm going to ask uh to see
it i'm pretty sure that my my team has
but i'll take a look at that myself and
i thank you for sending it to us
i know this is not even really the point
uh
i mean there is no point to anything
that this
empty-headed [ __ ] says in the first
place but
lgbtqi plus
you know he has to get the whole ad
that's not even close to the whole
acronym but
you know the i stands for intersex
so part of the concern is uh is is
we're focused on the fate of intersex
people in afghanistan
is that is that like a major concern of
the us government
intersex people in afghanistan
the fact that the eye gets included at
all
but just nothing to do
you know being intersex is a is it's a
medical condition
that has to do with the uh with the
appearance of your genitals
you know it's a it's a birth defect it's
a it's a deformity
it's a genetic mutation
and the way that we we put them in the
lgbt it's got nothing to do with it at
all
it's not a lifestyle choice it's not a
sexual orientation it's not gender
identity
you know i i often wonder how
intersex people feel about being
included of course
you don't hear from them very often
because there are very few of them this
is a very very thankfully
a very very rare condition
um
but even so
if
if that if if i had that condition
i'm not sure i'd be a fan of just being
appropriated in this way talk about
appropriation
and being lumped in with some group that
why why am i a part of that group
well the answer is
the reason why they're i'm asking all
this rhetorically i know the answer the
answer is that intersex people are
useful to trans people and like we
talked about yesterday trans people the
top of the of the victimhood pyramid and
whatever they say goes and so if if
you're intersex and trans people say
well we we need you on our team what do
you mean i don't want to be on your team
i'm not i'm just this is a medical
condition it doesn't matter we need you
here get over here
because of the of this false equivalency
that they can draw
that's what you get on the left they can
never argue about the actual point
you know they got to go all the way to
the rare cases that have nothing to do
with the main point
so you talk to anyone on the left about
transgenderism within 10 seconds they're
going to be bringing up intersex people
which is an entirely different category
that has nothing to do at all with a
biological male who identifies as a
woman the fact that some people have
genetic defects that affect the the the
appearance of their genitals says
nothing at all about transgenderism
whether it's valid or invalid
if i'm a biological male fully
biological male identifying as a woman
and you say to me well how can you be a
woman it doesn't make any sense for me
to say well but look at these people
over here they have a genetic they have
a medical condition yeah do you have
that medical condition no i don't but
they do and you know so that means that
i'm
what
all right
nothing what were we even talking about
oh yeah um intersex afghans okay
let's move on to the next topic here
from the new york post it's the ultimate
form of social distancing it says one in
seven vaccinated americans have ditched
pals who've refused to get the kova 19
vaccine according to a new poll
the one poll survey from monday found 16
percent of respondents have broken up
with at least three friends since the
pandemic began in march 2020
of those who ended friendship 66 percent
were vaccinated and 17 have no plans to
receive the shot about one in seven or
14 percent
of those have been vaccinated said they
dumped their friends because of their
refusal to get jabbed a vast majority of
vaccinated respondents 97 believe their
former friends are full-blown
anti-vaxxers who couldn't be convinced
of the importance of getting the
life-saving shot
and
well i
we need
some of the words being used here don't
really work because you say
they ended their friendships
there was never a friendship to begin
with so that's one thing you can be
pretty sure of
if you have a friend who won't speak to
you now
who's broken up with you
i don't know how a friend
breakup works in the first place
or you're just friends with someone
what do you actually call them up and
say i gotta break up with you
i can see maybe that's something women
would do
tending to be a little bit more dramatic
about these things no offense
i certainly hope men aren't doing this
are there dudes calling up their buddies
hey man uh listen we gotta break up what
break up what are you talking about
i can't see you anymore
you won't i got this substance injected
into my body and you won't get it
injected into yours and uh
you know i wanted to be vaccine buddies
with you i wanted to share the same
substance coursing through our veins but
you won't so i can't see you though how
bizarre
that was never a friend so you don't
have to worry about that if any if any
friend has broken up with you
um
first of all to begin with that means
that they're lame and corny and who
wants to be around them anyway
but that was never a real friendship
and of course it goes back to the same
contradiction
because one of the things that drives
people to
uh break up with their friends or
alienate their family members not want
to be around their family members and
their friends who aren't vaccinated
one of the things that drives that is
that they who are the vaccinated people
feel that they're
that
it would be unsafe that their health
would be jeopardized
if the other people around them don't
also have the vaccine
so their message is
and i've been trying to distill this
down to something very simple to
understand their mentality
and i think this is it this is their
message this is what they're saying the
vaccinated people who are
you know not wanting to be around
unvaccinated people
they're saying you must get the vaccine
to protect me
because i got the vaccine
and i don't trust it to protect me
i got the vaccine
and i've decided it doesn't protect me
and so you have to get the vaccine to
protect me
that's what they're saying
there there are a couple levels of
contradiction there which make no sense
at all
and the first problem is this
whole idea that it's someone else's
responsibility to make a medical
decision for their body for your sake
the idea that they have to make a
medical decision
forget about whether it's the right
medical decision or not doesn't matter
you're saying they have to make a
medical decision
about their own bodies
for you
how selfish could you possibly be
and on top of that you
you apparently don't trust the vaccine
to protect you anyway
so why should they do it
when you say to someone i'll get the
vaccine to protect me
what they should respond is get the hell
out of my face you weirdo
and if they don't if they don't want to
be that rude then then they could say
well don't you have a vaccine well yeah
i have it
and does it protect you um no
so why do i have to do it
there's no way around this they can't
get around it
so they so they simply ignore it
and you could say all you want well
yeah but it's layers of protection and
yeah the vaccine works to protect you
when you take it yourself but if someone
else gets it then you're even more
protected okay fine
so let me i'll add the word significant
into it
does the vaccine offer significant
protection or not
and if you tell me no
then i don't see how we could require or
demand that anyone put a drug in their
bodies that doesn't offer them
significant protection
if you say yes then you're significantly
protected get over it just move on with
your life
i mean that's the most you can ask for
in life the most you can ask for and
even sometimes this is too much to ask
for depending on what the risk is but
the most you can ask for in life is that
you are that you you you take
precautions that significantly protect
you against uh very various forms of
harm
there is no
absolute protection
the best you'll ever get when it comes
to protection against harm of any kind
is significant and sometimes with some
forms of harm you won't even get that
all right this is from the daily wire it
says students in new york city's public
schools returned to 100 in-person
learning for the first time since
schools began remote only in march 2020
but as multiple parents and outlets
report in person does not mean a return
to normal and may end up harming
students just as much as remote learning
did
uh
carol marco is a new york times uh marco
witch i think new york post columnist
with children and nyc's public schools
reported the harsh conditions kids face
in the new school year
uh she said my daughter's manhattan
middle school won't be using lockers
this year my sons brooklyn elementary
school let us know that water fountains
will remain closed no group projects no
field trips no parties outdoor resource
cess will be masked and distanced forget
tag or sports
this word is way overused but how
dystopian is this really
the image of masked children
outside during recess who can't come
within six feet of other kids
what are you going to draw circles on
the ground on in the grass
stand in your circle
give them a ball they can just throw it
up in the air themselves
you catch a kid throwing a ball to
another kid
grab the ball disinfect it
put the two kids in detention in
separate classes is that what we're
doing yeah that is that's that's what
we're doing
uh she pointed to a health guide from
new york's education department which
suggested schools cancel sports theater
clubs and all music related activities
because children might breathe too much
during them
oh my god
uh the guide states quote due to
increased exhalation
oh it literally says that okay
it actually says don't do activities
where kids will do too much breathing
exorbitant breathing is a is a is a real
problem now
maybe that's something kids will get
detention for get them suspended write
that on the slip
too much breathing
you know you know we you know we should
do we should assign we should tell kids
this is how many breaths you're allowed
to take in school
so let's figure out this this is what
and this is what we need to do for the
sake of the kids and for safety let's
figure out uh average school day let's
say it's seven hours how many breaths
will a kid typically take i don't know
how many breaths it is but you know i
don't know
and we'll figure out what the average is
you give them leeway of like five or six
extra gasps
and beyond that no breed we're gonna
count the breaths
go beyond that it's gonna be serious
consequences
the guide states due to increased
exhalation that occurs during physical
activity some sports can put players
coaches trainers and others at increased
risk for getting and spreading
covenanting
close contact sports and indoor sports
are particularly risky similar risks
might exist for other extracurricular
activities such as band choir theater
and school clubs that meet indoors does
it actually put people at greater risk
do you have any science for that any
data have there been any studies we have
any statistics are there any are there
any numbers you can show us
kids playing
physical
close contact sports like tag or or
whatever football basketball
i mean all sports almost are phys are
certainly physical
at a minimum so is there any data that
shows us
has there been an example anywhere in
the world
of kids
playing a sport outside
and there being a uh a coveted outbreak
because of it
has there been any super spreader
dodgeball game
i tend to doubt it
but again they're not allowed to play
dodgeball in school anyway that that
went away a long time ago
um
wrote that uh one manhattan elementary
school sent parents a survey asking what
they should do in case of inclement
weather
one of the options was actually skip
lunch
so they have to eat lunch outside
and they'll sit on the ground
some schools have forbidden students
from talking during lunch
and if it's raining or something then
they're gonna say well you're just not
gonna have lunch because that's
healthier
make the kids go all day that's the
healthiest thing to have kids wearing
the face muzzle all day breathing in
their own
sweat and dirt and grime
and don't let them eat either
on twitter she noted that students will
have to fill out a health form each
morning before school which asks if
they're experiencing any symptoms of
covid
and you know the problem with with that
i mean of all of these regulations which
are all insane
maybe if you don't think very much about
it the one that might sound the most
reasonable is
fill out a form and make sure you don't
have coveted symptoms
but we could all agree that if a kid
actually has covet he shouldn't go to
school um and he just like if there's
any other respiratory virus you
shouldn't go there's a flu we should go
to school
but you think about what the symptoms of
covid are
the symptoms are
headache
fatigue
runny nose
slight cough
the symptoms are anything
the symptoms are anything other than
feeling perfect
if you're feeling anything less than
absolutely perfect in this moment you
have coveted symptoms
and what that means is that kids either
are going to have to just get in the
habit of lying on the forum or they're
going to get sent home every single day
speaking of preparing classrooms for
covid the seiu
union tweeted a video of their covet
buster unit
preparing schools this is also in new
york
and let's play this here they are
preparing the uh this looks like a you
know some kind of first grade
or second grade classroom
preparing the uh the classroom for for
you know kids coming
what is he doing right now
does he even know what he's doing
looks like he's just spraying pesticide
into the air it would not surprise me if
that's what they're doing
you have kids dropping dead from
pesticides sprayed in the air
that's not actually what they're doing
youtube don't don't ban me uh well i
don't know they're pranks they're
spraying some sort of disinfectant into
the air
let's accomplish absolutely nothing
but it's all part of this um
one of the real diseases in our culture
right now the the do something disease
that's what all of this is about well do
do something anything at
all and so what you find in school is
that they're doing a lot of somethings
they're just doing things
ostensibly in response to covid none of
it
will have any positive health effect at
all none of it will prevent covid
you still see now
uh even outside the classroom
and i saw a lot of this traveling around
the country
uh there's a little bit less of it here
in nashville but in other cities
you go to a store the cashier is encased
in glass like hannibal lecter
we already know that doesn't do anything
that doesn't stop the spread of covid
if anything it makes it worse because
now you've got an extra surface
that can get uh dirty
and and also it restricts the the flow
of air and you and circulation of air
you want greater air circulation you
know put more obstacles in place
restricting air flow
and we know that
and yet they just continue to do it
because it's something
all right let's move on now to
reading the youtube comments
uh andrew clavin
i believe this is an impostor says matt
i agreed when you warned against
republicans using jenner to call dems
transphobes while we're the real
inclusive inclu inclusivists there's a
word
how is that different from saying the
licentious vmas are old hat while
conservatives are the real
revolutionaries in both cases an
arbitrary third value inclusivity or
rebelliousness is claimed as a way to
elevate our standing and in both cases
it distracts from our true values and
motivations please don't ban me
well i would never ban
the real andrew clavin from the show but
you the imposter our band sir because
um first of all i'm not proposing
rebelliousness as a value i'm observing
the fact
that um that this debauchery is meant to
be rebellious and instead it is tired
and dreary and boring and i think that's
a worthwhile
point to make
um because it is it is sold as as
something exciting and different and
and kids are told this
you listen to this music and behave this
certain way
that you're going to be you know taking
down the system tearing down the
patriarchy like the woman had on her
dress at the met gala
in reality this is the system
you're doing exactly as you're told
you're doing it exactly as the people in
charge people in positions of power want
you to do
and also it's dull and dreary and boring
like i said
so i i think that's an important point
and second
um you know
so-called traditional values are
revolutionary and rebellious in our age
that is another
statement of fact and i think it's an
important one
that doesn't make them right of course
so i take your point there and it's not
like that's my sole argument in favor of
them i'm not saying that's the only
thing that we should be saying in favor
of so-called traditional values
it is again an observation
but it is also true that young people
have a natural yearning to rebel against
the standing order
and i think that in this case that is
something worth harnessing
it's not all
it can be harnessed in negative ways
certainly but it's a way of taking what
can be
a positive attribute an inclination and
instinct
and directing it
towards positive ends
we do that a lot with kids on a
day-to-day basis just as parents we do
that
that is so much of parenting that's so
much of raising the next generation
is taking all of this excitement and
enthusiasm that that kids naturally have
and you don't want to simply tamp it
down
you don't want to drug them into
submission like they do in schools
but you also want to make sure you
harness it
in in the correct way
um that's so much of parenting and i
think that that's part of what i'm
talking about here
all right
let's see
username person says matt just so you uh
know many people in the black community
are against lil nas x's antics they're
trying to push this stuff on the black
community
and many are pushing back but it doesn't
get media attention
um
yeah this is this is something that that
i often hear i mean traditionally
and by the way unfortunately you are
banned for the uncreative username i
mean put a little bit more effort that
you know that i'm reading the comments
on air and you go with person
so you can make another username and
come back
but that's your point yeah this is some
this is this is something traditionally
it's been it's been thought that um
you know the black community immigrant
communities
you know the hispanic community
tend to be more culturally conservative
um
certainly more so than you know your
white liberal
yuppies
and yet
black community and immigrant
communities
by and large vote democrat and so there
is that uh that real disconnect there
all right let's see what else do we got
um
as we were talking about cities so this
is one you know i was saying i can't
imagine how anyone would choose to live
in the city and a lot of comments about
that i'll read one representative
comment here this is from joe schneider
says i live in nyc and i can attest that
your description of our lifestyle even
as a tourist is accurate we used to have
an incredible amount of culture and
artistry that helped offset the side
you're describing and for a couple of
decades we'd gotten our crime under
control but with kovid and de blasio
modern-day leftism now it's just an
expensive urine-smelling crime-ridden
[ __ ]
yeah there were other comments so
there's a lot of comments saying that
saying yeah this is exactly what it's
like in new york and many of these other
cities los angeles san francisco and you
know philadelphia baltimore on and on
um a lot of comments like that other
comments saying well hey
you're telling people to get out of the
cities that means that we're abandoning
the cities to this fate
shouldn't we stay in there and fight to
turn it around
i guess my answer to that would be first
of all you have to make whatever choice
you think is right for you but
if you're a single person
and you feel like you want to stay in
the city environment
partly for this reason to be a shining
light in the darkness
it's not a choice i would make but i can
respect that choice
i think though if you have kids
you know if you're a family and i get
that there are many people living
in cities right now with families and
they'd like to leave but they can't so i
understand that
but if you have kids if you have a
family and there's an opportunity to
leave you're able to
then uh
then i think you have to it's the same
thing i say with public schools
it's one thing if you want to fight if
you want to put yourself sort of behind
enemy lines and
you you want to subject yourself to that
but you're also asking your kids in
public schools your kids are the only
ones doing the fighting
which is why if there's an option to get
them out i think i think you got to
and it's the same thing with with the
cities
it's also i'm afraid to say probably a
losing battle
corruption and the rot and the decay in
in many of our cities
is so deep
and has been building for so long that
you know you stay there to try to turn
it around i don't know that you're gonna
be able to turn it around before it
destroys you so that's the real thing
you have to
grapple with
but thanks for all those comments there
is no issue more pressing than the
blatant authoritarianism being exercised
by the current administration vaccine
mandates are un-american and the
antithesis of freedom it's wrong it's
affecting all of us and we're ready to
talk about it tonight that's why you
should tune in to catch an all-new
episode of uh backstage where we will
discuss what's happening and how we
fight against it
um that's gonna be of course you know
backstage like every episode myself ben
shapiro jeremy boring michael knowles
and andrew clavin uh with a really
important issue to discuss tonight it
streams tonight at seven o'clock eastern
6 p.m central on dailywire.com and on
our youtube channel dailywire you don't
want to miss it believe me you also
don't want to miss
the new sweet baby gang t-shirts which
will couple well with the new sweet baby
gang anthem that you can now hear on the
show every day as expected the t-shirts
are selling out fast so you got to click
the link in the description to go order
yours today it is a masterpiece of
design i finally have
uh i had to you know i actually had to
ask to get my own tip i finally have the
t-shirt here myself and i should be
wearing it maybe i'll wear it today
tomorrow on the show but that is that's
the official sweet baby gang t-shirt um
if you haven't gotten it yet
i know who you are i'm keeping track of
everybody who claims to be a gang member
and has not gotten that t-shirt
and you don't want to know what the
consequences are because there are none
but still go get the t-shirt today click
the link the link in the description get
your sweet baby game t-shirt now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to the story of mma fighter and woman
beater alana mclaughlin now the most
important thing to know about mclaughlin
is that he is a male he's also former
army special forces
but mostly he's a male
and when i say he's a male i mean he has
xy chromosomes and a male reproductive
system and male gametes
so it makes a person a male he also has
a male bone structure muscle structure
he's male from head to toe from skin to
bone from his brain down to his cells
down to his dna
literally every part of him is male if
they dig up his remains 100 years from
now no matter how much of him is left
they will be able to tell that he was
male
that will indeed be one of the only
things they will be able to tell about
him
that's because your maleness
or your femaleness
is one of the most ingrained most
permanent most enduring aspects of who
you are it's so enduring that it remains
even after you die
mclaughlin will be a male even when he
doesn't exist anymore that's how male he
is think about that
if you're a man
even when you stop existing you'll still
be a man
and yet that didn't stop him from
fighting a woman in the mma ring during
the combat global prelims on friday
night mclaughlin fought and easily
defeated celine provost another mma
fighter to be more specific after
beating her across the head in the body
for a couple of rounds he eventually got
her into a submission hold and choked
her out
this was again a man beating the crap
out of a woman an event that in the past
would have been roundly condemned by
everybody when former ravens running
back ray rice punched his wife in an
elevator it was one of it was one of the
biggest sports scandals in nfl history
and rice was run out of the league never
to return
now we know that rice could have simply
come out the day out the day that the
security camera footage was leaked could
have come out and said um
said that he's a woman
asked everyone to call him regina rice
from now on
it's bad for rey to be to beat a woman
but regina
now
that's a different story
that's why alana mclaughlin is being
celebrated as a hero today after choking
a woman into submission but mclaughlin
is not the one i'm canceling today
yeah he's a cheater
a woman beater
a bad person for that reason
he's also a pathological narcissist
yes he's a he's a male who beat a woman
to a pulp and who identified fallon fox
as his hero fallon fox is the other
trans mma fighter who retired
a few years ago who twice fractured a
woman's skull and then bragged about it
so yes all of that is true and all of
that is worthy of cancellation to be
sure but as always
the bad guys disgust me somewhat less
than the cowards who knowingly go along
with the evil because they're too scared
and too selfish to speak out
and the announcers and commentators
during this farcical fight on friday
night give us a pretty good idea of what
that cowardice sounds like so let's go
through some of these clips first here
is one of the hosts before the fight
introducing alana mclaughlin and very
very gingerly acknowledging that maybe
some people in the viewing audience
might have a problem with watching a man
kick and punch a woman for 10 minutes
listen
back here on compate global with rodolfo
roman my name is max bretos and alana
mclaughlin will be fighting here tonight
and the topic of trans athletes
competing
obviously splinters the conversation
quite frequently
however whatever side you think about
and whether you think that the trans
athlete should compete one thing we can
all agree on the sacrifices one has to
make to make that decision is bigger
than anything any of us would do on a
regular basis alana mclaughlin has had
to overcome
many hurdles in her life and her career
it's a journey that only her have taken
let's take a closer look at some of
those sacrifices that she has had to
make
as early as i knew there was a
difference between girls and boys i knew
that something was different
i grew up mostly in south carolina my
upbringing was
not exactly
standard it wasn't usual my parents go
to church five times a week wasn't the
best childhood we didn't have a lot of
money and of course growing up a queer
kid in the south it was never going to
be easy my family definitely was not
supportive and are not today
his family is not supportive well that's
good news at least
you know like how he says uh yeah my fam
my upbringing was uh it was pretty rough
not usual my family went to church
that's all yes that's that's his only
that's his horror story of being raised
man
i had a pretty tough kid family went to
church
yep that was it
now i can tell you that i certainly
would not be supportive of my son
getting into the ring with women and
choking them on national television
that's not something that i would
support to put it mildly
and yet the announcer says that
we can all agree
that the sacrifices made by a male who
beats up a woman are bigger than any of
the sacrifices that any of us have ever
made have ever made
we can all agree he says
and what he means of course is that we
must we must all agree
we are required to agree
just as his employers have told him that
he must agree
that's why his facial expression and his
stuttering stammering
delivery reminds you of a hostage tape
this guy knows how hopelessly screwed up
all of this is but he's cooperating with
the charade
and that brings us to the fight itself
speaking of the charade
fast forwarding a little bit to where
the foregone conclusion is realized and
the man beats the woman
let's listen to the announcers as they
very carefully wrestle with the
implications of the spectacle that they
themselves are now a part of
big right hand i for one and uh just
full transparency i don't know what to
expect i don't know how to feel about
this
but i pull for a lot of mclaughlin
because you see what you've gone through
to do go through what she has done it's
it's a seismic change in your life but
it's the pursuit of happiness
absolutely but you know at the end of
the day max it really does come down to
technique and skills you could be as
strong as you want
but skill technique
will always conquer well i agree with
you there rodolfo but that's a that's an
argument people bring up and they'll
they'll beg to differ
the
does pretty well gets her on the ground
now as you can see our ground game goes
this is uh
provost the uh
uncharted waters yeah not your typical
wrestling double takedown as you can see
she had to hold her up there for a while
usually your arrestor goes straight down
for the knee area or even into the
ankles to be honest just to bring them
all the way down she had to lift her up
like a deadlift and then she brought her
down mclaughlin's got the back of
provost and now i haven't
mclaughlin victorious in her mma debut
via the rear naked choke had to take a
lot of pressure to get there
but she did
yup beat the woman in the ribs
uh had her bleed in the face choked her
out
now you hear them say uh if you can't
beat them join them well
if you want to beat them join them
in a lot of mclaughlin's case
now but the announcer says i don't know
how to feel about this but certainly
alana feels good and that's the most
important thing
i don't know how i feel or anybody feels
or how the woman getting pummeled in
submission right now feels but all that
matters is how the trans person feels if
it makes him feel feel good to beat a
woman who are we to judge the pursuit of
happiness
he says
this is the pursuit of happiness as this
this man is in the process of punching a
woman in the ribs
we all pursue happiness in our own ways
now i'm just paraphrasing the announcers
here a little bit and then finally um
here they are at the conclusion of the
fight
sharing their their closing thoughts
about everything that we've all
just watched
that was a game plan and it worked to
her advantage
kudos to celine she took the fight and
kudos to alana right now i'm sure a lot
of teenagers adults are emotional yes a
victory
for the trans community and
the conversations will go from here as
to
what's next for alana mclaughlin whether
this
should be part of the sport
right now that doesn't matter alana
mclaughlin has gone through hell in high
water to get here this was a fight that
was supposed to happen august the 6th
put on hold
finally here in the first week of
september second week of september it
happens
yes a lot of teenagers and adults are
emotional
what does that mean by the way a lot of
teenagers and adults are emotional
watching this what
and but they're having conversations and
the trans community is having
conversations
and there are some who might say maybe
that this shouldn't be a part of the
sport that this sport should not be a
staging ground for men to beat the hell
out of women some might say that but
that doesn't matter now because again
the trans person feels good he's feeling
very good about all of this and that's
what matters that's the only thing that
matters in the whole world the world
itself indeed exists simply to make
trans people feel good about themselves
all of us on our death beds when
surrounded by our loved ones
will surely ask ourselves one question
did i during my life make trans people
feel good about themselves and woe to
those who cannot say yes on that day
what regret what terrible regret
again i'm slightly paraphrasing what we
just said now you have to ask yourself
do any of these men hosting this fight
and commenting on it actually think that
any of this is okay or logical or
morally justifiable
no
they don't
yeah i can read their minds and tell you
they don't
we can say with certainty they don't
yet they cooperate with this grotesque
absurdity
and that's the story of our culture
isn't it
that's the story the story is not alana
mclaughlin the elana mclaughlins of the
world are not the ones driving the
radical social change that we're
witnessing
they're not the ones driving our society
over the cliff which is what which is
the the radical change we're witnessing
the change is as much the the same as
the change that a car undergoes when it
goes over a cliff and crashes on the
rocks below
civilization will not collapse because
of them
because of the ilana mclaughlins
instead the real revolutionaries
unintentionally
are all of the millions of normal
basically sane people
who know that what they're seeing is
wrong
who know that it is not okay
and they know why it is not okay
and yet they remain quiet
and then ultimately they're forced to
participate
in the evil that they oppose
but oppose silently in their hearts
where the opposition doesn't matter and
accomplishes nothing
you want to almost feel sorry for those
announcers who clearly want no part of
this
but are forced to take part in it anyway
but then you realize that they're not
forced
none of us are really forced
it's just that refusing to take part may
require sacrifice and many of us are not
willing to make the sacrifice
no matter how great or small
all we have are excuses
we make our excuses
while our civilization rots away beneath
our feet
i'm personally tired of the excuses
i'm tired of gutless cowards like the
announcers in that mma match
who could have refused to to be a part
of it
or you know what's even better they
could have said sure yeah i'll announce
this match and then they could have
spent the entire time talking about what
an absolute travesty the entire thing
was
that would have taken guts
they would have lost their jobs
they would have lots of people coming
after them
but we're at a point now where you have
to do the thing that requires courage
and if you won't do it then you're no
better than
anyone on the other side
and that's why today ultimately
the announcers in that match and all
like them are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire2021
poll workers inform republicans in
california that they've already
unwittingly voted on the recall of
governor newsome aoc wears a tax the
rich dress to a party full of rich
people and dr fauci wants to mandate
vaccines for air travel check it out on
the michael knowles show
[Music]